hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his article virtue ethics as a
resource in business robert audi is
going to examine something that that's a
really
central worry that people have when
they're bringing in virtue ethics
perspectives into really any context of
ethics but particularly
business ethics
and he asserts quite plausibly that
virtue ethics provides raw material and
at least a partial basis for
comprehensive ethical theory with
applications in business as elsewhere
and that's quite true and the more that
we
research robust virtue theories like
studying aristotle or thomas aquinas or
the stoics or even contemporary authors
such as those he mentions in his article
like aleister mcintyre julia anas we
find that virtue ethics does in fact
provide us with a robust set of concepts
that does allow a comprehensive theory
but the questions are
is this comprehensive theory really
useful in business
and there's there's two questions being
considered here one of which he frames
right after making that that point
can virtue ethics provide a standard for
virtue
in business as opposed to just in
general is it
directly applicable as virtue theory in
business and then
can it provide standards for right
action in business this is one of the
worries that a lot of people have about
virtue ethics it'll say you know you
should be a just person or a generous
person or a diligent person but then
what does that mean when we get down to
the nitty-gritty of the day-to-day
decisions that we actually have to make
is do we have
criteria that tell us what a person like
this would be
and
audi pauses here for a moment to make an
important point about aristotle and i
think you can say this about other
virtue ethics as well aristotle is going
to take character traits
as being
fundamental ethically more basic than
actions
ethical
themselves
making so
aristotle could be understood as saying
be virtuous in this way in this way in
this way and then the actions will
follow from that but how does that get
us the the actions that we need there's
another wrinkle as well he says
aristotle understood the virtues
in the context of his theory of the good
for human beings this good is happiness
or flourishing eudaimonia right it's not
a passive state but requires a life in
which actions and activities that
involve reason are central and the human
good is activity in accord with
excellence so far so good this sounds
pretty good but this that doesn't
actually resolve our concerns
so one way that he does address that is
by making a distinction between what he
calls
comprehensive and role specific virtues
and here it's actually worth dwelling on
something that he doesn't bring up
there's a tendency in early virtue
ethics uh when for example when socrates
is asking people about what virtue is
they bring up a whole bunch of role
specific virtues and socrates will
dismiss that and say no no we want the
really general thing and audi is is
actually saying well we actually want
both particularly when we're dealing
with applied ethics because those role
specific virtues play a really important
role in applied ethics and so we have to
acknowledge them so what is a
comprehensive virtue a comprehensive
virtue is as he says a virtue that it
impacts
virtually everything that we do and this
would be tied to his notion of field
some fields cover our entire life so
honesty is a great example he says it
impacts virtually everything that we do
certainly all of our social interactions
you can say well wait a minute it
doesn't it doesn't affect all of my
social interactions because i'm honest
most of the time
well then it impacted it right it's not
just when you violate a virtue that it
impacts it it's when you're doing the
right thing that it impacts it if you're
honest all the time well that's your
entire life right if you're always
diligent
if you're conscientious if you're a good
you know
person in terms of managing your
emotions well those are comprehensive
role specific he says this uh these are
virtues that affect our activities in a
specific role
so it could in fact be the case
that depending on what our role is we
need different virtues so
an entrepreneur
may in fact need courage to a different
extent or in different ways
than a employee working on the factory
floor right
the person who is the idea generator
may not need as much diligence as the
person who actually has to do checking
of the products and we could go on and
on he gives some good examples here he
says that here we go a role specific
virtue such as leadership may affect
only our activities in a specific role
in this case one in which we have
authority so the comprehensive virtues
are needed by all of us and he also says
they can strain the way role specific
virtues operate role specific virtues
are ethically essential for those in the
specific roles but may be beneficial to
others and so he gives some examples
here about like consistency
managerial roles these call for the the
virtue of consistency particularly in
behavior managers must be seen not only
as exhibiting justice which is a
comprehensive virtue but also reliably
consistent in policy and there could be
some cases where
you know violating policy could actually
produce a more just result but in in
most cases you need to actually follow
the policies if you're going to change
them there needs to be some sort of
warning that changes are taking place or
you've got to make a case for why this
is such an exception right
so this is a useful distinction and this
addresses the issue of what can it
provide a standard for virtue in
business the answer is yes
here's a more thorny question can we
provide standards for right action in
business and if we're looking at virtue
ethics in just a textbook form the
answer is no
but that's not real virtue ethics the
summaries that are provided in textbooks
are usually
sorely lacking if you want to understand
a real virtue ethics you need to read
real virtue ethics texts and those are
usually long complex and and quite
robust
it's a rewarding thing to do however so
we can ask how does virtue ethics
or evaluate
actions that people are doing saying
they're the right thing or the wrong
thing how do they say this action is is
a good action or a bad action and virtue
and vice the opposite of virtue these
are key criteria so he talks about
we might appeal to practical wisdom a
person of practical wisdom is a paradigm
of one having virtue
and aristotle actually brings this up
saying that the person uses a kind of
procedure finding the mean between an
excess and deficiency and so
audi gives the example of beneficence he
says if relative to my resources i'm
selfish and ignore others needs this is
a deficiency if today i contribute so
much to charity and prevented from doing
much greater good through contributing
gradually i'm excessive
good ethical decisions may be seen in
the light of these comparisons
and so prudence or practical wisdom
would help us with this he also
considers maybe we could use something
like an instrumental rationale
rationality approach of cost benefit
analyses that could be prudential
couldn't it and he says
well yes and no as you know
in fact audi has a great article where
he discusses the scope of cost-benefit
analyses within virtue ethics but they
can't actually be made
central to it he says
instrumental success counts positively
towards at least the virtue of prudence
and failure to avoid what is painful
towards folly but
this is not the whole of virtue and
we have to be kind of careful with this
but it's an interesting thing to
consider it does have some role he also
outside of this particular section of
the article we'll talk about
role models some people say well the way
to be virtuous is just be like these
people over here and so you find a lot
of books being published with
biographies of important people who
exemplify business virtues right
and
that's nice but it doesn't really tell
you what to do when you get into
situations that they
didn't run into
unless you actually understand what the
virtue is you're going to have some
problems so andrew carnegie who it was
vicious in some ways
could also be seen as virtuous in terms
of his beneficence right but what would
andrew carnegie do in terms of
supporting
grants for
artists who are people of color and have
been discriminated against i don't know
that andrew carnegie's life would tell
us anything about that right that's
that's not that helpful to rely solely
on role models in fact that's usually a
recipe for getting things wrong
finally we have um actual criteria again
if you look at robust virtue ethics like
that of aristotle or the stoics or
others you will find that they do in
fact specify criteria for right action
and as audi says these can provide
either necessary conditions or
sufficient conditions or conditions that
are both necessary and sufficient for
right action right action can be
equivalent to action in conformity with
virtue and acting rightly can be
equivalent to virtuous action so what we
do is we we look at the treatments of
the virtues the discussions of them
whether they're ancient or medieval or
contemporary and we say all right what
does it really mean to be generous what
does it really mean to be loyal what
does it really mean to be honest and we
can specify
considerably what these sorts of virtues
would require of us without descending
to the level of rigid rules that you
know are always held to to be binding we
can come up with some some rules of
thumb
and we can use things like aristotle's
doctrine or the mean to specify these so
we we do in fact have standards for
right action and business at least for
action that would be in accordance with
the virtues doing what the virtues
demand not necessarily what a virtuous
person themselves uh actually does
because the you know the motivation is
lacking there but at least doing what
the virtuous person does in mimicking or
following along the lines of their their
actions
you